carrying on from the uh
13 joe carter
you may question those of you who know
the
accounting and the carter you may
question that
that i'm sometimes saying things wrong
in your
eyes and uh yes i possibly
may say things wrong even do things
wrong
i remember cytosins he said he was the
same he often said things
that afterwards he thought about and
they were wrong
he also said that he know this many
times i
sense he was wrong as well we're all
humans and we're trying to become a good
martial artist and learn
martial arts so if there is
some incorrections then hopefully
i'll correct them i wanted to talk about
the 13
carter and
last time i said they were the first
three movements
and i'll just go through them again
h knee
sound she
now these are movements that uh
are breaking down and cytosensei in his
later years
he made us break them down and what he
would do is he would count them
like this
itch knee
knee knee
it's to make it so that it obviously
comes out
right he doesn't want you know it can't
be a 13 count carter
and in tai chi they call it 24
forms but it's got about 100 movements
in it
and so really him breaking it down he's
created it more
like within the tai chi there's a lot
more
so so what i'm showing here
is the broken down movements so itch
knee
shoes
okay so so we're going to end up with a
lot more than 13.
what i'm trying to do with these films
are i'm trying to break it down so that
you know
each section and how you should feel
how it should be the angles it should be
right so
there's one very important point that i
notice people do
in the car in both carters and they do
this
edge knee
son she
they count while they're doing it
now this is no good
you can't develop your coq and key
the key will not come out and be
released from you
because you're concentrating even though
you don't realize
you're concentrating on the counting
counting is destroying the build-up of
the coke here and the build
and the flow of the key
so i recommend you study
this way h
i
so that's the first four movements now
and this is what i recommend you do
learn either to count before or after
don't count while doing it don't count
while performing
the culture
my dog wants to come out here and
disturb us
by teaching you but she is part of
nature
half life so and there'll be sounds this
is uh how life is
okay so the importance is to count
before or after
edge
knee knee
she
in the carter we don't turn
in a different direction
we'll end with shear
and you can do this
keep going if you're in front of a
camera angles don't really
matter but the reason we change angles
in the partner practice
is because you've eliminated
this person you're now going to this
person because it's a multiple
martial art and that's the aim of why
you're moving
when doing the carter you can you can
really
how you want because it's a carter for
your
suburbs to be polished and your
key to flow and for you to feel free
but if you see the back of me you can't
then see what i'm
showing so i would do it like this
if i'm doing the cart in there switching
from the suburbs
edge
hatch
and from the other videos you don't look
down you place it
knowing where your own foot is it
doesn't matter if it's out
a centimeter or two the importance is uh
keeping the marshall sanchin the
awareness
okay so we're going to keep breaking it
down
but so far the first three movements
i've explained about the blocks
what they're for and the detail
the next thing we'll do is we'll explain
about going from
three to six okay thank you for your
time
and when the weather's good i will teach
outside
don't wanna get out